everybody thinks that if you're 22 and
you have an idea you're entitled to a
startup if there's any level of romance
left in this room about your idea
I'd like to suffocate it I'm a humungous
believer that ideas are [ __ ] and that
execution of the game I think the other
thing you guys should recognize is how
ridiculously lucky you are it's never
been better to be an entrepreneur like
right now right this second is the
greatest on top of the fact that the
internet is hitting the Shorty and every
users on a smartphone in blah blah blah
and we're at scale in parallel there's a
fuckload of dumb money chasing it and
looking at to give it to anybody they
can how many people here really really
think they've got their idea and they're
ready to go I really think you should
leave with all my [ __ ] heart like
leave right the [ __ ] like walk out of
this room and go do it
you can literally raise a million
dollars on your horseshit idea I want
everybody understand that like tomorrow
that can go away the bubbles burst no
[ __ ] kid with an idea gets dick if
you're sitting here like no I'm
entrepreneur I'm not just in the class
you need to seriously concentrate on
where we are at this exact moment in the
market and recognize how peaceful it is
for you how much of an advantage you
have you may want to seriously consider
take advantage of it